Our favorite horror movies often have more
going on than just a bunch of monsters preying
on ill-fated teenagers.
Directors occasionally offer nods to other
entries in the genre, sometimes in the form
of a fourth-wall-breaking Easter egg.
Keep a silver bullet and some holy water handy,
because these are some of the best hidden
details in horror movies.
Shaun and George
Shaun of the Dead is basically a 99-minute
homage to the horror genre.
Obviously, the movie's title is a play on
George Romero's second big zombie flick, Dawn
of the Dead.
Speaking of which, Shaun chastises Ed for
referring to the shuffling undead as the "Z
word"...
"Any Zombies out there?"
"Don't say that"
"What"
"That"
"That, the Zed word, don't say it."
"Why not?"
"Because it is ridiculous"
...which calls back to the fact that the characters
in Romero's movies don't call their antagonists
zombies.
And when Shaun tries to book a date for himself
and Liz, his phone book features an Italian
food place called Fulci's—a reference to
zombie-film director Lucio Fulci.
The name dropping continues throughout the
film.
We see Landis Supermarket, a nod to the director
of Michael Jackson's "Thriller" video, and
Foree Electric, which is named after actor
Ken Foree, who plays one of the main characters
in Dawn of the Dead.
And we can't forget Night of the Living Dead's
most iconic line…
"They're coming to get you Barbra."
Which was referenced in Ed when Shaun was
talking to his mom Barbra.
"We're coming to get you Barbra."
In return, Romero cast Simon Pegg and director
Edgar Wright in Land of the Dead.
King Kong vs. sumatran rat monkey
Peter Jackson will always be remembered for
his Tolkien trilogies, but the filmmaker got
his start making B-movie horror flicks.
He paid homage to his past in his 2005 King
Kong remake, which slipped in an awesome reference
to his 1992 gorefest Braindead, also known
as Dead Alive.
The animal storage hold on the ship features
a crate labelled "Sumatran Rat Monkey—Beware
the bite!"
This is supposedly the same strange creature
that starts the zombie outbreak in Braindead…
...and in the movie, it's said to come from
Skull Island, the same island that gave us
King Kong.
Teasing The Dark Tower
David Drayton, the main character in Stephen
King's The Mist is a commercial poster artist.
In the opening scenes of the film, Drayton
works on a painting of Roland from Stephen
King's Dark Tower series, which was later
adapted for a feature film starring Idris
Elba.
Other horror movie posters can be seen in
the background of Drayton's office, including
The Thing.
And speaking of The Thing…
Bad dog
The 1982 horror flick The Thing focuses on
a group of Americans working at an Antarctic
research station, where they encounter a shape-shifting,
parasitic organism that perfectly replicates
any life-form it absorbs.
But if you understand Norwegian, the film’s
plot is spoiled before it even begins.
As the film opens, a couple of Norwegians
are trying to slay a dog... which is actually
the shapeshifting alien.
They shout warnings about the alien in Norwegian…
...which roughly translates to, “That's
not a dog, it's some sort of thing!
It's imitating a dog, it isn't real!
With great power...
Years after Hitchcock set the standard for
director cameos, Sam Raimi put his own spin
on the tradition.
Raimi's old car, a 1973 Oldsmobile Delta 88,
appears in the Evil Dead trilogy, Drag Me
to Hell, and Darkman, among many others.
The car remains Ash Williams' ride of choice
in the Ash vs. Evil Dead television series.
And who could forget Uncle Ben riding around
in the iconic car in Raimi's Spider-Man?
With great power comes great responsibility,
but with a 1973 Oldsmobile comes great cameos…and
not-so-great repair costs.
Raimi versus Craven
Sam Raimi loves dropping references to other
movies, so The Evil Dead features an interesting
detail: A ripped poster for Wes Craven's The
Hills Have Eyes can be seen in the basement
of the cabin, right behind the table where
Ash and Scotty find the Necronomicon.
This refers back to a scene in The Hills Have
Eyes depicting a torn poster of Jaws, and
in response, Craven put The Evil Dead on TV
during A Nightmare on Elm Street.
Lastly, Freddy Krueger's bladed glove can
be seen in the tool shed in Evil Dead 2.
Raimi may have gotten the last laugh, but
we'll let you decide who has the better one-liners.
"This is it Jennifer, your big break in TV."
"Keep your damn filth bones outta my mouth."
Talking heads
In Stuart Gordon's Re-Animator, Dan Cain's
bedroom features a poster promoting the Talking
Heads film Stop Making Sense.
You know, the guys who did this:
"Psycho, Qu'est-ce que c'est, fa fa
fa fa fa fa fa, better."
The rock reference alludes to the antagonist
of the film, Dr. Carl Hill, who gets decapitated
by Herbert West, after which Hill's decapitated
head and headless body are brought back to
life by West's reanimation serum.
Somehow, Hill's severed head is still able
to control his body, so — that's right!
— we have a literal talking head in the
movie.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
horror movie Easter eggs are your favorites...